sans ces masques ou ses gants de
protection un possible de prêter main
forte au monde de la santé pendant cette
période de crise sanitaire
plusieurs étudiants de l'ue vs qu'une
ont ainsi pas pu débuter leur stage chez
les médecins généralistes faute de
matériel ce matin-là ils reçoivent de la
part de leur université une boîte de 50
grands et 50 masques qui ont chacun une
durée de quelques heures seulement si on
n'avait pas ça on ne va pas la
possibilité de les faire les faire
travailler on peut pas les envoyer au
front sans un minimum de de protection
individuelle parce qu'ils soient
réellement en première ligne par rapport
aux patients qui sont potentiellement
infectées a lu vs q les stocks de
masques constitué il ya plusieurs années
suite à l'épidémie de h1n1 ont été vite
épuisé l'université versailles saint
quentin a pu profiter d'une dotation de
80 boîtes de l' agence régionale de
santé et du matériel avait déjà été
distribué la semaine dernière on est
quand même confrontée à plusieurs
malades et donc et des personnes qui
sont plutôt fragile donc pour les
protéger pour nous protéger
je pense que c'est essentiel c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu difficile en
ville d'avoir démasqué donc là on est on
est bien content de pouvoir en avoir
chacun chacun une boîte quand on est en
stage chez le médecin généraliste trois
médecins généralistes mois chez qui je
vais donc ils n'ont pas forcément de
masques pour moi déjà que pour eux c'est
compliqué donc on est content de pouvoir
se protéger et protéger les autres
l'université versailles saint quentin
espèrent désormais une nouvelle dotation
de la part de la rs dans une quinzaine
de jours